yeah and part of that grind is like epic
failures or epic bombs on stage and yeah
every every comic I ask on here I asked
him a story of getting booed on stage or
just epic failure I know you've been in
like Memphis and you've gotten a fight
you've had to give people back their
money yes I'm sure the one that stands
out that you just like I'll never forget
this moment you know the toughest one
for me like I got a you know admit
probably the toughest one was in New
York and it was for like an industry
showcase and I was there it was you know
one of them ones where you feel like
you're gonna try to write jokes for the
audience right so you're gonna try to
change your on yourself to fit them and
I bombed I mean I walked up and bombed
and it was like a horrible feeling and
Steve was there actually I was there and
he literally walked onstage after me and
I mean it's just corporate environment
custody in the audience and they were
dining in like they just loved the fact
that he was just real like it he was
just like and he was like you know you
signa mean you look I'm just one of the
funniest dudes and a world power place
let him have it and that's when he was
like don't go didn't eat just basically
don't ever change my just do you if that
don't work then they don't work but
don't try to fit in like you know so
that was one of the most valuable
lessons I took I mean of course you took
some ELLs and many different times you
know we all have yeah it's the business
you know I mean is that so but it was
one that that particular lesson was one
that I was like okay I can use that one
yes all right and we're we're running
out of time here so appreciate your time
and even doing this before your show
here just in closing here is there any
other closing advice you have for
comedians over your entire career you
can kind of bestow on them like you know
the main thing is always try to get as
much stage time as you can I mean
time people just want to make it and
they have a couple of jokes in a and
they kill it whenever they go on stage
and they believe like that's all that it
takes but really the more that you
sharpen your knife your machete whatever
it is that you need on that stage and
have that ability to walk out there is
something that I you know always
recommend that people just and you know
try to make the money first you know try
to try to be great at what you do first
you know and then even to this day I
mean as you could tell I mean you can
hear from the roar of laughter in the
background I have a tendency you're
putting really sharp comics on in front
of me so that I have to go out there and
put in the work on these guys you know
that's what happens you can get you can
become a pro and get a little lazy and
and have the expectations of Fame but
when people spend their money they want
to laugh and they want to laugh for real
and so I try to put myself in a
situation where you have to go in there
and do the work like it's because guys
these both Henry and JJ these user they
out there throwing rocks at the crowd so
but uh but that's it I mean just stay
encouraged stay work and stay and your
mindset yeah and try to stay free of you
know independency trying to like write
things and be true to yourself and look
for the comedy and the humor and the
things that happen to you in life
[Music]
high breath